all right Marissa Bell is that right or
Marissa Bell did I say it right Marissa
yeah you said it right nurse Adele got
close I stabbed all around it anyway so
from Phoenix how can I help you well
good afternoon first of all days it's an
honor to talk to you you come I am
calling because I'm pretty desperate my
husband and I have just bought our house
last year and we are really struggling
to make Martinez make pretty much ends
meet so we asked you what happened that
you thought you could pay it when you
took it out was it bigger than you
thought or did you lose a job or
something what happened
I just after we bought our house we kind
of you know started buying beans for it
um I kind of just got more than what we
could afford gotcha
how much is your knowledge payment our
healthy men is 1300 right and what is
your take home pay a month a month we
make about about four thousand okay
together um but we do have we do have a
car loan and we do have some other that
my credit card much do you owe on your
car on our car we owe about forty forty
community van $40,000
yeah and you make 50 grand a year we
make about 65 a year yeah yeah and you
take home four thousand not on 65 nice
you're getting a big tax return are you
getting a big tax return hmm
no no when is your money coming out of
your checks going into going into 401ks
yeah I have some my I have my insurance
online like we we have kids we have four
kids we only have in show but I'm
talking about 401k money if you have
investments coming out of your checks at
work
yeah I do yeah you need to stop that
immediately you're broke until you get
this miscreant out okay you make sixty
five thousand dollars a year you drive
you have a car you owe $40,000 on you
don't have a house problem you have a
car problem that car is in the stupid
zone I know and we kind of need it
because like I said you don't need it
that's a wrap you don't need a $40,000
car you don't need a $40 car you want a
$40 car you need a $3,000 cars what you
need you need transportation is what you
need it does not take 40,000 our cards
are all for kids around you understand
that right well okay this is insanity
you're calling me up and stressed out
because of a stupid car sell it okay and
keep your house your house is high but
it's not your problem
your car is insanity that's the problem
cool you get rid of this car payment
your life is going to balance right out
and get your other debts paid off you
can get in control
this car is nutburger land seriously
it's not even close to being something
that's you smart is not on this page in
the dictionary okay it's just not even
near this I mean you just got all mommy
DUP and bought you a mommy car can't
hauling them kids around is what you did
and so I'm selling your car I'm all up
in your business right now reading your
mail this ain't your husband's car I can
tell by talking to you so kiddo you want
your life back tell you how to do it
amputate the vehicle this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]